The layout of the glider chart.
As I said, when you glance at it once, you immediately want to close the chart again.
There's almost a bit of a feeling of fear.
At least with me that's how it was at the beginning, when I first sat down with it.
But once you look at the structure from the ground up and pick out each of these boxes
and then put them back into the chart, it's no longer quite so insanely complicated.
Then you know in principle what each box and each line means.
And afterwards it's simply a huge number of them stacked on top of each other.
And sometimes it's still difficult to figure out which line belongs to which airspace.
But that's more of a visual problem.
So I'd like to try to walk you through the understanding of the chart a little bit here,
and build up the chart from the ground up.
So, as the first prominent line, there's the dividing line between the Mittelland and the Jura.
And the Alps.
It actually runs right across Switzerland, as you can see here.
Roughly at Lake Geneva, around Montreux, it cuts across through central Switzerland
to us in the Alpstein region and then on towards Austria.
And that's how Switzerland is divided.
And this simply has a topographic background:
in the Jura and the Mittelland all the mountains are of course much lower,
and in the Alps they're a bit higher.
And so the airspaces are a little...
have been pushed much higher up.
And that of course also has an impact on us as paraglider pilots.
We'll get to that right now.
As I said, G and E we can fly in at any time.
For C and D we need a clearance.
And for now you can simply picture G —
the blue bar — as a carpet that's laid over the whole of Switzerland,
over the entire topographic map.
And the carpet is 600 metres thick.
And the transition...
Then, above those 600 metres,
you cross over into E.
There we're still allowed to fly.
It's just a different airspace with different rules.
For us as paraglider pilots we're allowed to fly into both.
After that it gets interesting for us:
namely, where is the boundary at which we cross over from E into C
and aren't allowed to fly any higher.
Where, even in super thermals, at some point we have to say,
okay, I'm in a thermal that would keep climbing,
cloud base is higher up,
but we have to leave this thermal and make sure
that we don't get into C.
And that's where it becomes exciting and also very important
that we know where this boundary is.
In the Jura, as you can see, that is everything to the left of this cross-section,
this boundary sits at 3050 metres.
In the Alps the boundary is at 4550 metres.
So you can see, we already have quite a difference in height here
and of course also in the possibilities we have with the paraglider.
It's also very important to know — let's assume
this mountain here were 4200 metres high,
then we're still allowed 600 metres above it.
So in that case you could fly up to 4800 metres
and clearly above those 4550 metres.
The condition is simply that you never have more than 600 metres of ground clearance.
That's very important.
Now we've talked about these 4550 metres.
It's very important to know
that this only applies when the military is not active,
when the military isn't in the air and isn't training.
And when the military is out flying,
you see 'MIL ON' at the top left,
then something happens with this boundary:
it comes down to 3950 metres.
Below that you can see the military hours shown,
which are also printed on the glider chart
and very important to respect.
So it's always Monday to Friday,
from 07:35 to 12:05
and from 13:15 to 17:05.
Those five minutes of buffer are simply to exclude overlap,
so there are no collisions or incidents.
So very important: when the military is active,
this boundary in the Alps comes down a bit,
but is still clearly higher than in the Jura and the Mittelland.
So a quick recap here.
The transition from E to C happens in the Mittelland
at 3050.
In the Alps it varies depending on whether the military is active.
There's a small point I forgot here
with all these airspaces.
Airspace D, which is also controlled
and where we also need clearance even without radio contact,
applies above all in the vicinity of airfields.
So we have G, the carpet laid over everything,
above that comes E and above that C,
and D comes in mainly over airfields.
Into play.
Then all these airspaces are marked with what are called tags.
You see them here on the left in theory
and on the right how they look on the chart.
And these tags always have a lower limit and an upper limit.
There it's very important that you see the difference
between upright numbers and italic numbers.
If it's upright, it's above ground;
if it's written in italics, it's above sea level.
And the second big difference you see here with these numbers
is that the upper number is highlighted in blue.
A number with a blue background means
that this is the altitude according to the standard atmosphere.
Now you see how, in paragliding or paraglider theory,
all these topics are always somewhat related
and dovetail into each other somewhere.
In meteorology you've already heard a lot about the standard atmosphere.
Here it's again about exactly the same thing —
that the standard pressure is assumed.
So the number written in white is the actual, true altitude:
if you look at the GPS reading
or at a sign on a summit with the altitude on it,
i.e. really the actual hard edge.
The blue-shaded number is then the figure
that can also fluctuate depending on the weather,
because you simply calculate the pressure reading back to sea level
and always assume
that at sea level the pressure is the same,
namely 1013.25 hectopascals.
And why that's the case,
I'll try to bring a bit closer to you
in the next few slides.
We measure altitude based on a pressure measurement.
That means your instrument measures
a certain pressure,
unless of course we have an altitude reading from GPS,
but a standard altimeter,
which measures the pressure,
assigns a certain pressure to a certain altitude.
But this pressure fluctuates every day.
On a mountain summit,
on the Säntis for example,
the pressure is not the same every day —
it varies daily.
And so you would actually have to
calibrate such an altimeter before every launch,
set it to launch altitude,
so that it is correct on that day.
But it's also the case
that over the course of the day the pressure can shift a bit,
and then in the evening after landing
the altimeter can already be off by a few metres again.
And for that a solution has been found.
And this solution is called flight levels —
Flugflächen.
And it comes from international aviation.
Because aircraft
that fly from one place to another
over greater distances
also pass through different weather zones
and different pressure systems.
And that would mean
that you would essentially have to
recalibrate the altimeter every few metres or every few kilometres
of flight,
would have to reset it to the local ground pressure.
You'd somehow have to keep radioing in,
what's the weather here,
what's the ground pressure here,
so that this altitude is correct.
And that would of course be almost impossible
and extremely tedious.
And it would also carry the risk
of perhaps immediately making a calculation error,
or that the pressure swing changes at exactly the wrong moment,
and that there would then be collisions.
And so in aviation people agreed
that you don't fly by actual altitudes,
but by standard pressure.
Standard pressure, as I said,
is 1013.25 hectopascals at sea level.
And now I have a quick little calculation example
before we go back to the flight levels
and how it works in practice.
Just so that you can picture a little
what that means.
So the example with Flight Level 100.
One flight level is 100 feet.
That means Flight Level 100 is 10,000 feet.
And because one foot is 30.48 cm,
Flight Level 100 is then 3,048 metres.
And so we see the connection again,
or we can explain to ourselves
why, for example, in the Jura
airspace C starts at 3,050 metres.
That is namely Flight Level 100,
and comes from airline aviation.
And it's exactly the same in the Alps.
The 3,950 are Flight Level 130,
and the 4,550 are Flight Level 150.
And at lower altitudes it's of course important
that an aircraft can fly to exact altitudes.
Simply because of the topography,
so that there are no collisions with mountains
or with obstacles.
But at a certain altitude it really doesn't matter so much any more
whether the aircraft cross paths up here
or cross paths a little lower down.
The most important thing is simply
that the aircraft are separated
and don't fly at the same altitude.
And that is precisely what was introduced
with the flight level.
Because you can see, when an aircraft
flies from a high into a low,
the curve doesn't have to be this extreme of course —
this is a bit exaggerated for illustration —
but then the flight level fluctuates a little.
So the aircraft drifts a bit,
goes a little higher, a little lower.
But it is always on the same pressure —
it flies on exactly the same pressure surface.
And then it really doesn't matter
whether it's at 11,000 or at 10,900.
What's important is that the aircraft fly at different levels.
And that they can avoid a collision that way.
Application in the glider charts
appears above all with TMAs and with airways.
We'll come back to those later,
and how they're structured.
But simply, if you look at the tags here again,
with the D, airspace D,
they always have a lower edge.
Here it's ground.
Here we also have a lower edge of 2,250 and 2,600.
And that is fixed.
It's really important here
that it's fixed, because of the topography.
This is the example of Meiringen here,
where there are very high mountains on the left and right.
The upper limit, the 3,950,
there we're back in the range
where it doesn't matter at all,
because there are no more obstacles.
That altitude can then fluctuate.
And that's explained a bit more on this slide.
So you can see, we have a piece of topography here.
This lower edge is very sharp,
because if this here were to fluctuate based on pressure,
then we'd have a problem here.
Then suddenly a TMA,
an approach corridor,
would run right into mountain terrain
and could cause a collision.
The upper edge, however, does fluctuate.
And how much that amounts to,
you can see here.
It's also interesting
to know for when we're paragliding.
By the way, this is also printed on the glider chart,
these numbers.
So you can see,
at 1,037 hectopascals
ground pressure.
And that is, well,
calculated back as the ground pressure,
that's of course already very high —
a strong high.
And there it amounts to about 200 metres.
Conversely, in a very deep low-pressure area
it makes for minus 200 metres.
So that's already quite a lot.
What you can also say:
in such a deep low we're probably not flying,
as a rule,
because it's simply really bad weather
and a storm is forecast.
In an extremely strong high we are,
we might do a glide-only flight
from a high-Alpine peak,
but probably also less of a thermal flight,
because it's just too stable again.
Now we're again drifting a bit
into meteorology.
But most of the time we're in the range
of perhaps plus,
perhaps even 100 metres,
in the air doing a thermal flight.
And the good thing is then
that these boundaries above all tend to move upwards.
So if you know,
above is an airspace
that starts at 3,050
and you're on a thermal flight,
then it's mostly the case
that the boundary is a bit higher.
But that's of course exactly why it's important
that the instrument is set correctly
and that we don't fly into it.
After that, for a change, an exam-style question
that could come up for you
at the paragliding theory exam.
You can see here:
the upper limit of airspace class E
over the Jura is asked for.
Then you have to first think about,
well, how high would it be normally?
Jura, as we said,
regardless of whether military is active or inactive,
the upper limit for us is at 3,050.
Now we have a very strong high.
At first glance you see lots of numbers
and immediately get the feeling,
oh wow, what exactly do I have to calculate now and so on.
But actually,
you're not required
to perform calculations.
You just have to see,
hey, this is an insanely strong high.
With a very strong high,
it makes at most about 200 metres.
And here you quickly see:
3,900 or 4,100 would of course be far, far too much.
It doesn't shift by that much.
It moves within a range of plus or minus 200 metres,
if such an exam question comes up for you.
Now we've made a small detour
in the direction of Flight Level.
Slightly off-topic from the glider chart,
but I think it was necessary
for the understanding
of how the airspaces are structured.
I hope
it has helped you a little.
Now we'll come back
to the other airspaces.
Here is now airspace D,
which I briefly touched on earlier.
Those are the CTRs,
the control zones,
which sit in the immediate vicinity
of the major airports.
And they always go from the ground
up to a certain altitude.
The altitude and also the shape
are of course highly dependent on the topography
and also on the approach corridors
and on the needs of that airport.
And they're of course not always round.
This is just shown symbolically.
Above that come the TMAs,
the terminal control areas.
You can again picture them
like boxes stacked on top of each other.
With TMAs there's something a bit special.
So here for example a CTR.
Then you have a TMA,
where the box actually runs into a mountain
or into terrain.
That happens sometimes.
And here it's really important to know
that with the paraglider
— but caution, only south of the dividing line
Mittelland–Alps, so only in the Alps —
you'll fly out 300 metres below it.
That happens in very few cases.
That's also an exam question
that's a bit tricky,
where you might get caught.
Watch out with these 300 metres.
Of course there are launch sites
where for example you launch here
and can wonderfully fly out below these 300 metres
down here
and are absolutely legal at all times.
And don't need a clearance for it.
Then we also have the airway.
That then connects the larger airports
and also the main traffic axes
of international air traffic.
Here once again a small side view.
You see, there can be multiple TMAs.
There can be five, six, seven TMAs.
There can be only one.
It really varies.
And as I said,
it depends entirely on the air traffic
and on the topography of the airport.
The activity of these TMAs
and these CTRs can also vary.
If a 9 is shown,
so we have the designation CTR LSZR here,
if a 9 is shown,
then it is permanently active,
as for example in Zurich at the major airports.
If it's HX,
then it has no fixed operating hours,
but you basically have to assume
that it can be active at any time
and that you can query the status.
And then there are the temporary ones.
The temporary ones are then announced via the DABS,
when they are active.
In Switzerland there are only two cases:
Sion and Alpnach.
We'll come back to this example a bit later.
Those are the three activity states of TMAs and CTRs.
In Switzerland we have a whole lot of heliports.
They're marked like this.
And we have to keep a radius of two and a half kilometres
from them.
Smaller airfields without CTRs are marked like this.
They have a radius of five kilometres
from which we have to keep our distance.
Here we have another little summary.
Here in the Lucerne area,
this is somewhat the Bermuda Triangle for us
paraglider pilots,
where we really have to watch carefully
not to enter anyone's airspace.
But a really beautiful flying area.
And you can certainly fly there,
even if it looks very, very complex here.
On this picture you can see all the examples
that exist.
So there's the heliport with two and a half kilometres,
the civil airfield.
Then there are mixed airfields
that are used for military and civilian purposes.
And then there are purely military airfields,
which are circled in red.
Also interesting:
it only goes up to 600 metres above ground.
So you could fly more than 600 metres above it
without getting into trouble there.
On this topic it's also important:
if you've planned a cross-country flight somewhere
and have the feeling,
this is where my ideal flight route and the thermals go,
and the angle of the terrain and so on,
and my route would actually go right through there
or would just barely scrape the heliport,
then it's definitely worth the time
to quickly follow up
and check at the SHV under the local agreements
whether perhaps for this heliport
there is even a local arrangement.
If you don't have any further info,
you always have to assume
it's a two-and-a-half-kilometre radius
and a five-kilometre radius at the airfields
and 600 metres.
But perhaps it's like here at Trogen,
where a wedge has been cut out,
where you can absolutely fly through the area.
And in addition you see
that here it now says Ground to 1200 metres.
Trogen, however, is about 800–900 metres.
That means it's clearly less than 600 metres as well.
And that can help you a lot
later in practice,
if you have such additional information.
Then we also have obstacles
marked on the glider chart.
They look something like this.
Here the Säntis example.
We have the obstacle.
At the top it says it has a light.
That's more important for aircraft
that are out at night,
to know that it's lit.
For us, less interesting.
What's also interesting for us
is to see the height.
And here it comes into play
with the italic font and the upright font.
Italic means above sea level.
So that's the top of the antenna.
And the 124 metres, the upright font,
that's how tall the antenna actually is.
So you know,
okay, the antenna is this big,
I should be able to see it from far away.
It just gives us a little reference point.
Also important are the cables
that are marked.
With these 100 and 264 metres
it simply gives the maximum clearance above the ground.
So here too you can estimate a bit
how big these cables are.
Very important,
watch out,
not every obstacle
is shown on the glider chart.
There are many obstacles
that aren't in here.
For that you should also look at the aeronautical obstacle chart
as well.
And even when you've checked that,
fly with your eyes open.
Don't just blindly fly into somewhere,
because there can always be
a logging or hay cable strung up somewhere
that, by law, doesn't have to be charted.
And that can become your downfall.
So always fly with your eyes open
and also talk to the locals.
And at the clubs and associations
and also at the valley stations of the cable cars
you'll usually find pretty good info
on such aeronautical obstacles.
So on this topic don't rely a hundred per cent
only on the glider chart.
You also see plenty of these.
The LS-Rs, the red ones.
The red Rs
are Restricted.
So we're not allowed to fly into those.
On the glider chart
the ones that are very frequently active
are marked.
And then again we go into the DABS
the evening before, to check
whether it's also active on the day
I want to fly or not.
Then there's also the LS-D.
That's not Restricted.
That's Danger.
There you can in principle fly in.
It's just not recommended,
because dangerous activities may be taking place.
Like shooting exercises, for example.
On the ground below.
And then to fly straight into that airspace
is of course not recommended.
But in principle not legally forbidden.
Here we have an example of such an LS-R
in our region.
Above the Alpstein and Lake Walen.
LS-R 3.
And here you can again see
the lower and upper limits.
They're shown shaded in red here.
And that again means
that the whole atmosphere is red.
And that the whole box of the training area
of the military can fluctuate.
It can sometimes be a bit higher
or sometimes a bit lower.
Here marked a bit better,
so you can see it clearly.
A short explanation about the DABS.
You'll find the DABS at www.skybriefing.com
Right at the start, very important input.
Always check that the date is correct.
Because if you look at the wrong day
and have the feeling
that you can fly in everywhere,
and on the day you're actually out
some shooting exercises are taking place,
that's of course very unfortunate.
Always check that the date is correct.
Here you can see on this map
the LS-Rs marked in red
are not widely spread.
There aren't very many active.
The one over our Alpstein isn't active either.
That doesn't mean they have to be active all the time,
just because they're on the glider chart.
Those are simply the ones
that are used very often.
That's why they're permanently on the chart.
But on the day itself you have to
always quickly check the DABS.
I've taken the D12 as an example here.
Near Einsiedeln.
Here you have, of course,
very little information about it.
And down in the legend
you can then see when
and up to what altitude
this airspace is closed.
Or whether it's declared as a Danger Area
instead.
And also what's going on down there.
Here too I recommend,
just have a look from time to time.
Even if you maybe aren't going flying
and are stuck at the office that day.
Just have a quick look.
It's sometimes interesting what else you discover.
And here it's still
extremely important to watch the time.
It's in UTC.
UTC
is the standard time.
In winter we have to add an hour
for Swiss time.
And in summer add 2 hours,
to get the active time.
So if it says here
it's active from 07:00,
then in summer it's only active from 09:00.
Depending, that can be good for us.
Or it can not work in our favour.
And shorten our flight time a bit,
the time we get to fly through there.
As chance would have it,
on this,
in this DABS,
the temporary TMA of Sion was
active.
You don't see that very often,
but it's perfect for showing
the three activity states
that a TMA
or CTR can have.
Sion and Alpnach,
as I said, are the only ones
that are communicated via the DABS.
And here you can see right now
how it then looks.
On the glider chart,
it's a very subtle detail.
You can barely see it,
but the border is a bit finer.
That's why this TMA
is to be handled somewhat differently from others.
Now we've talked an awful lot
about restrictions,
dangers, limitations.
Now I'd like to talk about
something very positive
on the glider chart.
About a relief for us
paraglider pilots.
And those are the LS-R for Gliders.
Those are the glider zones.
They are marked in green.
It is also LS-R,
but it isn't restricted for us.
It's restricted for instrument-flight aircraft
or instrument-flight
aircraft.
And it's therefore a relief for us,
where we get closer to the clouds.
We'll get to cloud clearances
shortly.
And what exactly that means.
The LS-Rs are active from 1 March
to 31 October.
Here too,
watch that you look at those times.
And that you don't, for example,
on a super good day in February —
that can happen —
go thermal flying
and aren't even aware
whether the zone is active.
So watch out
that you only really start using them from 1 March.
And also for the exam,
for the theory exam,
but also for the theory question at the practical exam,
if you take your exam in winter,
it can happen
that the examiner asks a sneaky question
about the glider zones,
which then happen not to be active.
Visually they look like this.
Outlined in green.
Here too we have lower and upper limits given
on the glider chart.
If we talk about these LS-Rs,
we inevitably also come right away
to the topic of cloud clearances.
The cloud clearances are regulated such
that up to 300 metres
above ground
you don't need a cloud clearance.
You just have to be outside
the cloud at all times and also
be able to make a 180° turn.
So you can't fly head-on into a cloud
until you're almost inside,
but you must always be able to turn around.
That's very important.
Horizontal visibility
must be 1.5 kilometres
and you must always be able to see the ground.
This rule applies up to 300 metres.
It's a bit special.
It's not simply said
that it's in airspace G,
but it's only half of G.
So it's only 300 metres
and not 600 metres,
where the line is drawn.
You have to remember that.
Everything that's above 300 metres
must then keep pretty large cloud clearances.
Vertically it's 300 metres
and horizontally
1,500 metres of distance from the clouds.
In terms of visibility it's
no longer just 1.5 kilometres,
but it then goes up here
to 5 kilometres,
respectively 8 kilometres,
as soon as we're flying above 3050.
That simply has to do with the speeds
of the aircraft,
because higher up
higher speeds are flown
and of course more time is needed
to react and avoid.
The aircraft fly into the clouds
and when they come out of the clouds
and we only have 500 metres of clearance
from those clouds,
it can under certain circumstances get tight.
That's why we have
larger cloud clearances higher up.
Except in the special case
of the glider zone LS-R for Gliders,
it looks a bit different.
In these zones
we have, namely,
a minimised cloud clearance.
That's 50 metres vertically
and 100 metres horizontally.
On the right-hand side
you can again see
the lower limit and the upper limit
of this airspace.
Here it's still important
that you don't get confused
or think
that at 2450,
in a super thermal,
you have to stop and fly down again.
You are definitely allowed
to climb above that altitude.
The only thing that then changes,
as soon as you're above it,
are the cloud clearances.
If you, for example,
are at 2500,
then the large cloud clearances apply again.
That is still important to know
and sometimes at the theory exam
the questions are posed in such a way
that perhaps
you trip up and think
you can only fly up to 2550.
But that doesn't apply to the flying,
but only to the cloud clearances
you have to keep.
Many of these LS-Rs
don't have any suffix at the back
and just the altitude.
And some have
a suffix at the back
of MO.
MO means it's only active
when the military is off.
So when the military
is not active.
MA is also always active,
when the military is not released.
With MA the difference is,
when the military is active there,
it can be
that it's then immediately
released.
If the military is active
and MA is shown, you can ask.
Perhaps it then opens
the airspace right away,
because the military is perhaps
at another location
or isn't using the airspace.
Now we've heard a whole lot of theory.
I hope
you're still listening.
Now we come to a theory question.
As warm-up
for the theory exam
and of course also
for your flying life.
We're standing at the launch site
and have to know
how high I fly,
what are the cloud clearances,
how far do I have to see,
and am I legally underway
or should I even launch at all?
Dear Silo.
Basically I always ask myself
the five questions
when I'm at a point.
On the one hand it's the season
because of the glider-zone period.
Am I between March and October
or am I in winter?
That would affect me in the glider zone.
The second is the day of the week
and the time of day
because of the military,
to know how high I'm allowed to climb
if it's going great.
Then I have to know,
am I north or south
of the dividing line?
Am I in the Mittelland or in the Alps?
The altitude I'm currently at
is very important to know
and so is the location.
Am I within the radius
of a restricted zone?
That's very important.
If you can answer these five questions,
then you also come
relatively quickly
to the solution.
Maybe you can quickly press pause
and not yet go on to the next slide,
and think about the task.
On the next slide
the explanation comes right after.
You can see, it's location B.
It's a maximum altitude
of 3,050 m,
because we are north
of the dividing line.
It's a bit nasty here,
it's right at the border,
but slightly above or to the left of it
means we're in the Mittelland.
The answer with 4,550 m
you can actually already cross off.
Very often, as far as the theory exam is concerned,
you arrive at the correct answer
through the process
of elimination.
Flying forbidden —
I see no reason for that here.
We don't have an airfield,
no heliport nearby.
Not in a Danger or Restricted Area,
to be more precise.
It all looks like flying is fine.
The altitude is
the same for B and C.
Now we have to figure out
how it is with the cloud clearances.
We're up at 2,700 m.
That means
visibility is 5 km.
We see that here.
Next to the legs it says 5 km,
because we're still below the 3,050 m.
Higher than that we're not allowed,
because we're in the Mittelland.
As for the cloud clearances,
we have to consider
whether we're in a glider zone or not.
That's a bit mean.
You could think
you're inside.
But if you look at the numbers
for the LS-R21 carefully,
the LS-R for Gliders
only goes up to 2,450 m.
But we are already
in the air at 2,700 m.
That means
we are above it.
We may fly there.
It's not forbidden.
But unfortunately we have to
again keep the large cloud clearances,
so 300 m and 1.5 km.
So I'm trying to send you off
with the approach
of proceeding
by these criteria,
so that you're always legally underway
and can also answer questions for exams
correctly.
Then we have here once again
a small example.
We have to go through everything.
Here, watch out.
We see
we're up at 1,850 m.
Airspace D goes from 1,600 m
up to 1,350 m.
So you're rather quickly tempted
to say it's forbidden.
There I'm right in it.
Flying forbidden.
Either don't launch,
tick 'flying forbidden' at the exam
and move on.
Think it through here again
really carefully.
These are the special rules
that work in our favour.
We're here in Meiringen.
It of course helps
if you know the chart a little.
But here we are south of the line.
You're in the Alps.
That's why the special rule
comes into play,
that you fly through 300 m
below the TMA.
And we are,
as you can see up here,
at 150 m above the ground,
legally underway.
With a maximum altitude
of 300 m above the ground, of course.
Here no altitude
above sea level is given,
because the ground varies as well.
If we follow the terrain
and simply always keep the 300 m,
we're therefore legally underway at all times.
It's only 300 m,
so cloud clearance:
no cloud clearance required,
fly outside the clouds
with a 180° turn possible at any time,
and ground visibility.
I'd like to thank you for your attention.
Thanks for listening.
I hope I was able to give you something to take with you,
so that as a first step
you can approach this positively,
can go in,
can prepare yourselves for the exam,
and then as a second step of course
have lots of fun in everyday flying
and that you are at all times safely
and legally on your way in Swiss airspace.
Many thanks.
See you soon.